[Music]
in the lobby of ramsay solutions on the
debt free stage with the matching
t-shirts it is derrick and amber how you
guys doing we're doing really good we're
nervous but we're good
so where are you guys from
we're from salt lake city utah very nice
okay so let's talk about this how much
debt have you guys paid off we paid off
61
373 dollars awesome and how long did
that take
that took us eight months eight months
yeah and what was your range of income
during this time we started about uh
forty four thousand and ended in about
160.
whoa
oh i'm gonna need that story yeah did
someone did someone get a job here how
did you
quadruple your income
um well kovitt kind of came and i was
working at a youth treatment center and
they didn't need the help anymore um and
he's a tattoo artist and his shop closed
and we were actually living off
unemployment
and my student loans
um and that's why our income was so low
and then things started opening up and i
finished school and i got a job at the
social worker in child welfare
and then he went back to work so and
plus we had some side hustles in there
so wow so business came back with a fury
apparently yes we were ready were people
coming out of the pandemic going i need
tattoos man
what is going on here seriously
i just um
all i did was work you know and and and
my books just started feeling and i and
i um
so so during
um
when coveted came i mean when closed
down i actually uh were both recovering
addicts i ended up relapsing and i went
to jail and um so we during that time i
mean i didn't we didn't have my income
you know um
i ended up getting out of jail and um i
went to a treatment center and then
we read the book again
and uh we started listening to this
podcast this podcast every day it was
our motivation and um back in november
we we downloaded that app uh the every
dollar app and just stuck to it and um
listened to the podcast every day that
was our motivation i went back to work
she graduated college and went and went
to work and um
we worked every day every day
tell me about that's so interesting as a
part of your story tell me about how
having this goal
and this plan
affected your relationship affected your
stability affected your focus in other
areas of your life having this this plan
that that you guys were so disciplined
about how did that affect other areas of
your life
um i think
for us it affected our communication so
i mean we we had to really sit down i
mean i thought i was gonna have my
student loans forever like i just
accepted that like i'm just gonna have
this payment forever but like sitting
down and and like it takes courage to
look at yourself and be like okay well i
spent way too much money eating out or
do you know what i mean like to be able
to talk to each other he didn't know how
much student loan debt i had fully was
this all of your debt the 61 000 in
student loans no what was that what kind
of debt was this
we had uh student loans um
that was my major portion but we also
had car loans we had medical bills we
had um
i i when i when i went to jail i ended
up racking up back some back child
support um we
we had a
little bit of credit card um we even had
debt on our phones i mean we i think we
upgraded our phone through our service
and
you know just everywhere um
yeah so what got you started on this
journey eight months ago
to go you know what this is it no more
so i mean it was a couple years
a couple years ago a friend of mine had
given uh i didn't know what audibles was
back then and he had given me
the book the total money makeover and i
we listened to it and then we were kind
of dave ramsey yes you know for a little
bit but then when the pandemic came um
when we both lost our jobs um
and and that whole situation happened
with with me going to jail and um
when when i
it's just what happened what i mean
which
i never said we um
we're just listening to the podcast
every day um and starting every dollar
out that's that's what changed us um it
was the motivation hearing everybody's
stories um it was it was nice and it was
losing like being so low and being
scared yeah um with neither one of us
working even though we had the
unemployment it was we were still like
kind of living paycheck to paycheck are
we going to be able to pay the rent are
we going to be able to buy food we had
our car payments
um and so i think being kind of and then
him going and i was by myself
you know i was scared i didn't have an
emergency fund to pay the rent yeah um
we didn't have anything to fall back on
but having that now it's kind of
it's nice
talk to me about now like you guys have
been through it in the last two years
what does it feel like now standing on
that stage you're completely debt free
you have an incredible income you've
turned your life around what does that
feel like
um it's free
um and peaceful actually um
like my whole life i think like i've
always waited for payday you know when
payday like let's
i can't do this because i don't get paid
like i i forget about painting payday
now
i mean i get reminded by people at work
they're like it's payday and i'm like oh
is it i had money before payday
i don't have to wait for payday like if
that's right and we were able to bring
his parents on this trip they've never
been out here um we we came early and we
went and ran the spartan race we can
travel and do the spartan races like we
like to do and
um
i think it's just strengthened us and
and motivated us even in more ways to
just continue with our kids
my son he saved a lot of money and
bought his own car six thousand dollars
wow awesome
we actually have envelopes for his kids
um
and his daughter is the sweetest we she
put money we don't tell them where to
put their money
and we'll have like a payday meeting on
sunday they do jobs around the house
they have to check it off and
she was putting money in her give
envelope because we're on baby step 3b
so we want to buy a house
and she was putting the money in her
envelope and we looked at her and we're
like what are you planning to give like
what's your plan and she says well i'm
gonna i'm gonna keep putting money in
there and i'm gonna give it to you guys
to help buy the house
oh my gosh
incredible yeah look at that look at the
example you're setting but the legacy
you're creating you guys are amazing you
all are amazing well thank you for being
here and sharing your story what a story
of resilience i know it's going to
inspire someone out there who may be be
going through something that you guys
were eight months ago a year ago so
thank you for being here we've got a
copy of the legacy journey for you
that's obviously the next step for you
guys and you're changing your family
tree in so many ways not just with money
but you guys have taken control in all
kinds of areas and we have a copy of the
total money makeover i know that
inspired you and it's going to inspire
someone else you can pay that forward so
we're so honored you guys made the trip
to be here tell me what the t-shirts say
on there yeah so i'm gonna read hers
he's the tattoo artist so he designed
him i love it so we have matching ones
on the front that say team beast
her says if broke people are making fun
of your financial plan you're on the
right track i'm debt-free
i love it and now you guys get to scream
it okay you ready you gotta get more
okay
so it says don't buy things you can't
afford with money you don't have to
impress people you don't like
brilliant that's perfect that's a long
tattoo to put on skin but it works great
on a t-shirt
okay let's do this guys it's derek and
amber from salt lake city 61 thousand
dollars paid off in eight months making
44 to 160 thousand dollars count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one we're different
oh this is one of my favorites i've seen
in a long time look at them
i love that so much